Let's talk now, more specifically, about processes.
And, we'll start first by understanding, what is a process?
To do this, recall that one of the roles of
the operating system is to manage the hardware on behalf of applications.
An application is a program that's on disk, in flash memory, even in the cloud.
But it's not executing, it's a static entity.
Here, for instance,
in this picture, we have some application that's stored on disk.
Once an application is launched, it's loaded in memory here, and
it starts executing.
Then it becomes a process.
So a process is an active entity.
If the same program is launched more than once,
then multiple processes will be created.
These processes will executing the same program, but
potentially will have very different state.
In fact, very likely they will have very different state.
For instance, a process can be one instance of the word editor program.
Here, you're displaying some notes from a previous lecture.
And perhaps you're just reviewing it, you're not really modifying this.
And then you can have a second process, another instance of
the exact same word editor program to take notes from this lecture.
Given that we just started, this probably doesn't have many notes,
so it has relatively small state, and it may have some unsaved edits.
So, process therefore represents the execution state of an active application.
It doesn't mean necessarily that it's running.
It may be waiting on input like user input to type in certain notes.
Or it may be waiting for another process that's currently running on the CPU,
in case there's just one CPU in the system.